okay kane kevin reality tv's new dynamic
duo are you ready for your lives to
change with this tv show
so already i'm over with 2020 and like
i'm super excited for 2021
[Music]
the asians are here
i think it's very important to have fun
anna shea
my first question at the gate is have
you figured out instagram because it's
about to blow up for you
i'm trying i'm doing my best why did you
want to uh
add reality tv to your already very
very interesting life well you know it
um it's not necessarily the reality tv
part that was exciting it's the movement
towards cultural diversity that
is playing out on both cinematic arts
and and television arts um
and i'm really honored to be included in
this project
to progress positively in that direction
kane you seem to kind of be the
connector for everybody the person that
everyone in this group
knows so can you explain to me how this
show came together and
how this friend group came together so
i'm sure you're familiar with like the
movie crazy rich asians right so after
that home movie came out there was a
huge
um you know demand in asia especially to
find out
to know like who these people are who
are these real
families you know instead of watching a
movie they want to know who these
family are in asia so you know i was
obviously one of them that they
sort of based the book on so there's
through because of this demand my friend
kelly and i were like oh my god like
let's
do something together and we had this
idea to do like a reality show together
and then slowly but surely like you know
the whole cast kind of came together
and you know i've known christine for
like you know
um five six years kelly for like seven
years
actually kevin's the newest person i you
know that you know i've got to know
so yeah yeah and kelly introduced me to
kane because i was moving at los angeles
and kelly found me on social media
and then i met kane for the first time
and i remember you know i'm like i am
not going to get along with this guy
and then we just hit it off i know it's
crazy it's crazy we come from such
different backgrounds but like yet like
i don't know just something light about
kevin that you know that
we you know we click on are you single
here
am i single yet blast her
out you're putting more diamonds in her
treasure what do you hope the viewers
walk away
from season one of bling empire feeling
and thinking
i'm hoping that the audiences will
resonate with our personal stories and
journeys that we
really shared so authentically and in
really raw form
um the struggles that affect both
wealthy and not
and the triumphs that we have
experienced as well
and we hope that that will inspire
strength and those who might be facing
the same challenges
we all have we all go through the same
problems like a lot of people
to me you know and it's it's way
deeper than all the blings
well let's let's dig into some of those
problems that we explore in this season
kelly your relationship with andrew
is tough to watch at parts you're way
overreacting right now right now
yes or no you don't [ __ ] drive that
way there ain't no dick
that good it's definitely hard to relive
a breakup and really
relive a very dark time in our life but
i think um
there's no regret whatsoever um
everything happened for a reason i think
also this show really helped bring all
of our problems that
we've been kind of avoid dealing with to
the front right so we were able to
grow a lot actually through this this
process and
as hard it is to watch i'm just really
happy
that we got it on camera you really lay
it all out there when it comes to your
family stuff
on the show i want to know what your
in-laws think about you doing bling
empire
okay well the in-laws that's um i think
that's a
that's a tricky situation from for any
any person
whether asian or not and i'd like to
think it's particularly
trickier with an eastern cultural
background
just because of the generations of
expectations
and pressures um
i don't know how they feel i hope they
do not watch the show
and i'm secretly i'm trying to figure
out if they have netflix
because i i think that it's still a very
touchy subject um and it would be for
any family to be
discussed on a global platform
so for that i'm very sorry in-laws
i'll produce another son for you i
promise
kane how does your family feel about you
opening up
this kind of private world oh my gosh i
just spoke to my dad yesterday and i was
like dad i have to
you know i apologize if i'm putting my
health my family out there
you know but he knows netflix he knows
it's such a big platform and
you know he's like you could do use this
platform and
have so many other opportunities you
know be it with your work
or like helping people raising awareness
so i mean
they didn't say they're proud but i feel
like you know
um maybe inside it might be a little so
we'll see
looking back at season one any regrets
kim maybe the drink throw what drink
i feel like crazy attracts crazy do i
regret that
absolutely not at that moment
at that moment no and i like i was like
ooh did i get it on the oh well
i mean i did not go into this show
thinking
a penis pump would be at the center of
drama
tell me about it
she has a penis pump what she had a
penis pump
in their shower
oh that's somebody's juice i throw it
outside outside
[Music]
oh my god that's a penis pump
this is this is not a screw you
situation this is a [ __ ]
situation the penis pump
the answer the infamous penis pump
can you give the people an answer why
was that in your shower
yes penis though
was in the guest bathroom show
okay not in yours so it wasn't yours
no but it was embarrassing to
my guests is this a guest we know
no no okay so i didn't expect
people to walk around my house if i were
a producer
right now how can i see how please don't
use it no
so you gotta go with flow it was there
they found it right or wrong it doesn't
matter
it's done it's there it makes for good
tv
i don't think so oh what really
if the show does come back for another
uh
year what would you want to see the
group take on in a season two
are you kidding it's taking me so long
to do instagram
i've never watched a reality show
so i'm just going with the flow they
tell me
well what the scene tells me i just i
just
am okay it's hard to plan these things
if some
something happens you just have to kind
of go with
what i think i'd love to go to south
korea
i'd love to go to south korea with
everybody not just to
be like oh where my parents at you know
you my dad you might you know but like i
think it'd be a good cultural experience
because i think
kane always pushes me to be more korean
you're too white
you're white no i think it's good for
you kevin i
i personally bryce i think traveling is
going to be a huge thing
i would actually like to fly the whole
cast to
singapore um and you know showcase like
show them
um what singapore truly is so definitely
for season two i would
love that i would love to see kim find
love and i would love to see kevin find
love on season 2 as well
why are we laughing you guys should be
bracing for impact the show's out there
the dms i think on both ends are going
to be flooded
what is your message to those who might
be uh trying to slide in there
because he has a lot of girls right now
signing in
hey kkk this is my type like if you're
my type uh you'd
be more than happy to slide in take your
shot
your type then oh man i love well
obviously i
i'm more gravitated beauty wise like
towards asian
obviously but i've actually discovered i
really like colombian as well
so that's also my type uh is like
ratchet
he likes the wild ratchet type
i mean as long as they're okay with like
the attention that i get i'm totally
cool but yeah they need to be a little
ratchet get down and dirty a little bit
once in a while
i definitely i'm gonna give love a shot
because
all my life i've always been you know
this strong independent girl
that's all about get your career first
and love's always gonna be there but i
feel like if i
put all that energy into love
it might work so i'm open to that that's
where i'm at right now so i'm actually
manifesting i'm praying every day i'm
like you know if i can manifest that
would manifest this
is love does love mean kevin
you know kevin's got great traits too
but then
i know too much about his dating life so
i
right right uh yeah i think yeah the dms
will be flooded on
uh friday saturday sunday and kane what
about you what if people try to get in
your dms
oh my god i've been getting a lot of
vm's regarding like collaborations and
stuff which i'm really excited about
i want free [ __ ] but kane
i meant like the suitors like a love
interest may be sliding in there not a
corporation
oh my gosh brian i'm not focused on that
right now
all right guys anything else you want to
say about bling empire what people
should take away from the show
your favorite moment anything
oh my god i was gonna say
rip the shirt off at the end
i really hope people take away from this
especially asian communities i think
we'll be proud of something
in the reality space we have so much in
media and like
movies tv but reality space where are
the asians
so i think it's really especially as
american
i think it's going to be something
they'll really be proud of and can
relate to when they get beyond just
the bling and the fashion part of it so
i just hope people enjoy themselves and
just take the show and like just
you know have fun with it
you